à
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue d'un point de
vu l'émission où les plus belles
intelligences de ce pays
débattre de l'actualité du jour et
l'actualité du jour
aujourd'hui eh bien c'est la visite en
france du président égyptien al sisi et
les déclarations du président de la
république qui emmanuel macron disons
qu'hier que la france n'avait pas à
donner des leçons y compris en matière
de droits de l'homme est ce un tournant
dans la stratégie dans la politique
étrangère de la france
nous en débattrons l'homme que vous
voyez là c'est évidemment christophe
castaner il n'est plus seulement le
porte parole du gouvernement
il est le futur délégué général de la
république en marche s'il a été préféré
à benjamin griveaux et si le président
de la république encore lui qui l'a
choisie tout cela est il bien normal
démocratique
logique on en parlera nous parlerons
aussi des républicains qui n'ont pas
réussi hier à se mettre d'accord
exactement à atteindre le quorum
suffisant pour exclure les constructif
dont le député thierry solère c'est
constructif qui soutiennent de façon
plus ou moins directe
emmanuel macron et puis nous parlerons
de l' affaire de harcèlement sexuel des
rebondissements de ce dossier avec la
proposition de nicole belloubet de créer
une loi sur les outrages sexistes et
puis le dernière révélation en date
c'est l'ancien président américain
george bush père qui est accusé de
harcèlement sexuel nous y reviendrons
avec nos quatre invités bonsoir
elisabeth lévy on est très heureux de
vous accueillir dans le point de vue
vous êtes la directrice de la rédaction
de causeur en une de votre magazine ce
mois-ci paris 2024 aller jouer ailleurs
un dossier qui réjouira ceux que vous
appelez les gie aux sceptiques
vous êtes aussi l'animatrice de l'esprit
de l'escalier chaque dimanche sur radio
rcj avec alain finkielkraut votre
dernier livre les rien pensant j'insiste
les rien pensante est paru il ya
quelques jours ou même ces jours ci aux
éditions du cerf
bonsoir et roanne 97 et céistes
consultant en stratégie maître de
conférences à sciences po chroniqueur
chez nos confrères de l'opinion votre
livre la france des opportunités toutes
les bonnes nouvelles qu'on ne vous dit
pas est paru aux belles lettres
bonsoir et me leclerc
vous êtes directeur d'études chez oddo
ksa france institut de sondage désormais
bien connue même si c'était un petit
nouveau dans le monde des instituts de
sondage trois ans et bientôt l'âge de
raison et bonsoir renaud girard vous
êtes bien sûr le chroniqueur
international du figaro que les lecteurs
de ce quotidien imminent peuvent
retrouver tous les mardis dans ses
colonnes et vous êtes l'auteur de quel
diplomatie pour la france prendre les
réalités telles qu'elles sont c'est paru
il ya quelques semaines ou quelques mois
maintenant aux éditions du cerf vous
avez le même éditeur kelly la bête lévis
excellente et dit excellent éditeur
tueur est la preuve c'est qu'il fait
preuve de discernement dans le choix de
ses auteurs je vous propose de commencer
cette émission en parlant bâton de la
visite du président égyptien al sisi que
des déclarations du président de la
république française emmanuel macron dix
ans que nous n'avons pas de leçons nous
la france a donné aux pays tiers en
matière de droits de l'homme
écoutez le président de la république et
donc de la même façon que je n'accepte
qu'aucun autre dirigeant me donne des
leçons sur la manière de gouverner mon
pays je n'en donne pas aux autres et
bien souvent avec les meilleurs
sentiments du monde
nous avons su créer la situation que
nous connaissons en irak
la situation que nous avons eu à
connaître en libye ou à vouloir donner
des leçons
hors de tout contexte et à mettre à bas
des systèmes politiques qui ne
partageaient pas nos valeurs nous avons
produit quoi l'anomie des morts encore
plus certaines et de la violence
radicale cheikh renaud girard votre
modestie dut-elle en souffrir
j'ai l'impression de lire une de vos
chroniques ce que ça fait longtemps que
vous dites ça d'être les îles et les
pays sont pas faits pour pour faire de
la morale mais pour être efficace et
lucide c'est que je te fais d'ailleurs
le sous titre de mon livre prendre les
réalités telles qu'elles sont que le
président n'a plus qu'à sûrement le je
pense qu'il est lui pour la campagne
électorale effectivement le valais
et je suis je suis effectivement j'ai
beaucoup combattu l'attitude par exemple
de laurent fabius
vous vous souvenez que laurent fabius
par exemple ne voulez pas vous voulez
organiser une conférence sur la syrie
agenais sur l'apéro série et ne voulait
pas convoquer cette conférence l'iran il
acceptait de convoquer la norvège mais
pas l'iran parce que l'iran était un
pays méchant et faisait donc de la
morale alors mais moi j'avais expliqué
avec un majeur de la christian rouyer
que qu il a on n'a aucune chance de
résoudre la crise syrienne si l'iran
n'est pas à la table de négociation
puisque c'est le principal allié avec la
russie du régime de bachar al-assad je
pense que le prix de la république a
raison de dire ça je pense que la france
ne doit pas rayonné doit rayonner par
son exemple bien sûr que nous sommes
attachés aux droits de l'homme
nous les avons inventé et je suis très
content que nous profitions là tous
ensemble de la liberté d'expression mais
dire après les avoir juste après les
avoir écrits les avoir inventés en 1789
on a fait quelques petites exceptions
1992-93 pas parce qu'on avait une guerre
voilà voilà
et donc nous savons aussi faire des
exceptions mangeant pense que nous
devons rayonner dans le monde pas notre
exemple c'est à dire la france
effectivement un système politique qui
marche bien
un système économique qui marche bien
système social est sous thèmes éducatifs
et que ce modèle est un système tout tu
allais je suis je suis mais je ne suis
pas pour la diplomatie de la leçon
morale à des drames à 6 à la hollande ou
à
à la même à la face à ce qu il soit
sarkozy aussi et cette diplomatie qui
consiste à vouloir faire par là par la
force et parfois même de tous les pays
du monde l'équivalent de nos régimes
puisque cette cette politique est finie
vous savez c'était c'était jules ferry
qui disait la mission civilisatrice de
la colonisation mais ça c'est fini nous
avons renoncé à sa en 1945 et donc je
pense que macro a tout à fait raison de
dire que ce n'est pas lui a géré la
guerre qui fit qu'il faut reconnaître
que le président si si on hésite il est
le gars il est en guerre contre les
frères musulmans et contre l'expérience
une interview au figaro qui va te donner
cette semaine il a donné une figure hier
et il est en guerre c'est à dire il a
des rues 30 ou policiers qui viennent de
ce fait tomber dans une embuscade dans
le désert libyque et qui ont été tout à
fait je pense que par ailleurs macron
peut pas derrière parce que je crois
aussi à la diplomatie secrète je pense
que c'est très important qu'il ait du
secret dans la diplomatie
je pense que par ailleurs ça permet à
macro de 2,2 d'assister sur des dossiers
personnels etc
comment comment vous les chinois je
pense que ça sert strictement à rien de
dire aux chinois vous êtes des méchants
vous êtes des mauvais fait que nous ça
ne change rien et me leclerc le sondeur
que vous êtes
c'est ce que pensent les français de ce
sujet est ce que je trouve que la france
c'est d'abord le pays des droits de
l'homme et que on doit être des exemples
voire parfois de l'élection ou
patrouilleurs les français sont attachés
aux droits de l'homme oui il nous disons
à longueur de sondages maintenant on les
a pas interrogés particulièrement sur le
canal si si
mais on peut penser oui que les français
et peuvent comprendre ce que ce que vous
dites avoir savoir cette idée que on
peut parler droits de l'homme en privé
et on peut soulever quelques questions
comme l'ont fait d'ailleurs la plus la
majorité des présidents par le passé
sans pour autant afficher clairement
médiatiquement et au vu et au su de tout
le monde
pointé du doigt un pays qui ne
respecteraient pas les droits de l'homme
tels qu'on les imagine dans en occident
plus largement camp français elisabeth
lévy allez vous vous indignez l'open
jeunes en ont au contraire
renault qui y est allé dire que les
peuples n'aimait pas les missionnaires
beauté je crois bien que ce héros bester
d'ailleurs qui n'était pas comme renault
l'a rappelé particulièrement un parangon
des droits de l'homme je dirais
donc ça je crois que maintenant on a
tout à fait raison en général il a
surtout raison pour l'egypte
rappelez-vous mais enthousiasme délirant
auquel il était impossible d'échapper
sur prétexte d'être traité de raciste et
d'arabophones au moment des printemps
arabes
quand on disait attention ces pays ne
sont pas exactement des structures
d'état des mots des structures sociales
démocratiques et donc c'est pas en
plaquant des élections que ça va marcher
on disait il va y avoir l'islamisme à la
sortie des urnes qu'on se faisait
traiter mais de tout plaisir on était
vraiment des [ __ ] des achats lavit
plateau en plateau en disant vraiment le
lire vous aimez rien vous n'êtes vous
voulez pas la liberté pour les peuples à
rome au printemps ramon voit ce que ça
donne est donc maintenant je pense que
dans toutes les chancelleries on a une
trouille bleue d'une chose c'est que
l'egypte ne tombe
c'est vraiment la dernière chose dont on
a besoin si vous voulez donc alors bien
sûr les journalistes au isadore comprend
dick des leçons de morale si la
politique étrangère de la france vous n
ont pas à la corbeille
mais dans les médias ces volets ou des
relais dans la rédaction du monde
ja diront leur passerait notre temps à
donner des leçons de morale au monde
mais j'ai été étonné le nombre dans
votre propos vous n'ayez pas citer des
néo et néo conservateurs c'est parce
qu'il n'est pas trop long c'est pour ça
ok ok dit bon voilà
herbal dedans non ce qui a été dit je
trouve ça assez rassurant en réalité
cette position de les manuels macron
parce que je vous [ __ ] une vision
assez réaliste des relations
internationales c'est l'intérêt de la
france qui comptait donc quand il faut
aller
travailler avec des pays qui ne sont pas
des idéaux démocratiques travailler avec
eux c'est pas nécessairement les
premières impressions qui m'avait laissé
à moi mais je suis peut-être moins
l'avis pelé internationale que d'autres
quand il est au début de son mandat
quand il avait tapé sur trame taper sur
poutine montre en enroulant un peu les
dents mais les avait reçus mais en en
affichant bien fortement que il avait
une critique et poutine sur les sur les
droits de l'homme il avait critiqué le
trump pour le courant sont à mon sens en
commentant la vie politique interne
américaine une certaine façon trouve que
l'ail qu'ils montrent que en réalité ce
qui compte de son point de vue c'est
l'intérêt politique du pays et son
intérêt politique à lui et c'est assez
qui échoue finalement assez rassurant ce
que c'est très rationnel ce qui est très
intéressant se trouve maintenant dans le
petit livre que vous avez montré à
l'écran
jeudi j'ai une théorie de l'ennemi
principal c'est à dire que je pense
qu'il faut pas faire la guerre à des
gens qui sont pas nos ennemis presse
vous vous souvenez que françois hollande
voulait faire la guerre à la syrie de
bachar al assad en septembre 2013 et
simplement nous n'avons pas fait la
guerre à gaza parce que les américains
et les britanniques se sont démobilisés
aux derniers membres
moi j'étais pas pour faire la guerre à
bachar à sa soeur qu'il est certainement
très cruel c'est certainement un état
policier en syrie là bas mais parce que
nous avons un ennemi principal et c'est
pas bachar al assad s'est pas bachar al
assad qui tue nos enfants dans nos rues
ce sont des islamistes qui tue nos
enfants dans nos rues et effectivement
dans le désert dans l'est dans le désert
libyque épieront en cyrénaïque aussi les
français et les égyptiens les forces
spéciales françaises et l'égyptien main
dans la main combattent ces djihadistes
qui commettent des attentats au caire
mais qui en commettent aussi en afrique
- qui dès qu'ils veulent descendre qui
en commettent évidemment en tunisie qui
est nôtre notre allée qui veulent
envoyer des djihadistes sur la france
donc effectivement nous avons un ennemi
sa macro l'a bien aidé
bien la mienne isolés cet ennemi il bay
va prendre tous les alliés possibles
alors si cette année des possibles
contre les sionistes et même disons le
poutine est tout à fait en dix ans
passant de cynisme quand même là dedans
écoutez c'est presque encore plus
cynique si vous voulez de faire la
politique de l'émotion parce que dans le
fond pour faire bien pour faire plaisir
à vos opinions qui réclament de l'action
qui épie parce que derrière on vous dit
des enfants qui ont tous des enfants
vont mourir
donc on vous fait ou vous la fais à
l'estomac donc on veut dire en gros vous
êtes un peu coincé vous devez intervenir
et après ses volets celle après moi le
déluge
regardez ce qui s'est passé en libye
alors encore une fois là je pense qu'il
faut pas que l'occident soit trouve
outrecuidant et prétendent que tout
vient lui je ne sais pas ce qu'il serait
advenu signé du régime de saddam hussein
ni du régime de kadhafi qui ne serait
pas illégitime itema semble-t-il
tellement énorme
si on n'était pas intervenus mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que à chaque fois qu'on
fait ce genre de chose qu'on va avec nos
grands pieds nos bons sentiments si vous
voulez qu'ils sont très louable on ne
peut pas faire de ça ça se termine mal
on ne sait pas quoi faire après parce
qu'on ne va pas reconstruire les états
nous si vous voulez le problème c d et
ce sont des étapes à légitime et c'est
hier qu'est ce qu'on fait après on est
englué regarder les américains il
voulait partir
je suis d'accord il avait très vite je
crois qu'on va jamais arrêté les skoda
tu es déjà avant la guerre de 14 des
interventions d'humanité oui il est
spécial mais je pense qu'il faut les
encadrer et c'est ce que j'ai expliqué
dans ce sens il faut des trois
conditions premier conditions bon vous
voulez virer un moustachu qui s'appelle
saddam hussein bashasha qui vous voulez
kadhafi c'est vous le remplacer par quoi
vous l'embrassez part ça vous remplacer
par qui c'est le premier critère est ce
que vous avez une équipe de remplaçants
fouquet par les étés de mickey que nous
avait montré notre ami bernard henri
lévy l'hôtel raphaël qui l'avait ramené
à sarkozy sur la libye côté du rhin
capable de gouverner la libye ils ont
entraîné alors par leur incapacité là
est-ce que vous avez une équipe de
remplacement la deuxième
la deuxième question vous avez vous fait
ça pour protéger les populations civiles
vous le dire vous obtenez l'autorisation
de l'onu au nom de la protection du
devoir de protection des populations
civiles
est-ce que vous pouvez simplement leur
garantir que leur situation sera
meilleure
après l'intervention militaire qu'avant
il se trouve que je suis retourné
plusieurs fois en libye après
l'intervention occidentale et susurre
retourné plusieurs fois en irak après
l'intervention occidentale je n'ai pas
trouvé une seule famille de benghazi ou
de tripoli ou de bagdad qui ne
regrettera pas le régime en syrie il me
disait me 6,7
même si oui et je pense je parle bien
des je parle bien je parle bien des
chiffres parce que parce que parce que
la bri atur politique
les gens n'aiment pas ça mais il y a
pire tu fais d'un futur il pas dire il y
à la marche il appert que l'anarchie et
à la guerre civile
effectivement les familles chiites de
bagdad elles ont peur maintenant
d'envoyer leurs enfants à l'école c'est
le pire pour une seule image et c'est
pour ça voila voila je ne parle pas des
familles chiites du sud c'est un peu
différent car vous m'avez parlé de
bagdad et là c'est tout à fait tout à
fait en version que vous avez couvert
pour le figaro tous et tous ces conflits
et d'autres je voulais donne les
commentaires de nos internautes qui sont
assez d'accord avec vous ives aguila qui
nous dit nous sommes jugés comme étant
arrogant dans les pays étrangers et
particulièrement dans le monde oriental
team nous dit on lance des bombes et on
oublie l'avenir s'écrit si ça nous dit
carrément il n'y a plus de droits de
l'homme ça n'existe plus quant à josh
hill se réjouit de la présence
d'elisabeth lévy mais nous aussi et sug
nous dit on cherche toujours l'onu trois
petits points vous venez vous venez d'y
faire allusion et revenant est ce que ça
veut dire que cette idée traditionnelle
selon laquelle le développement
des pays ça allait de pair avec la
démocratie c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut oublier aussi c'est à dire qu'en
fait on disait aussi les droits de
l'homme c'est utile parce que c'est un
facteur objectifs de développement pour
un pays non je crois que ce soit mais je
crois pas qu'ils soient d'ailleurs le
discours du président de la république
ait pas de dire qu'il faut oublier les
droits de l'homme mais c'est de dire que
d'abord c'est l'intérêt de la france qui
passe en premier et donc j'en vois tout
ce qui a été expliqué à l'instant mais
il ya aussi l'idée que dans le
développement ce n'est pas ce n'est
probablement pas que les droits de
l'homme et que peut-être que les droits
de l'homme soient aussi la conséquence
de dinde et un d'un développement
économique et de ce que disait il avait
très vite alors d'avoir une société
civile qui soit suffisamment forte et
prête et ava gardner les institutions
suffisamment compte par nos solides pour
mettre en place une démocratie
donc je crois pas du tout qu'on est
ni nom ni en france ni ailleurs l'idée
que la démocratie soit pas faite pour
certains pays ni que la démocratie ne
devienne pas un jour dans ces pays là
mais par contre on est revenu sur l'idée
qu'on pouvait avoir dans les années 2000
à la faune mois après la chute du mur de
berlin qui est de dire on va forcer la
convainc accélérer l'avènement de la
démocratie dans certain nombre de pays
idc les droits de l'homme que la
démocratie elle est arrivé comme par
miracle avec le marché comme le montre
évidemment l'expérience je sens comme le
montre l'expérience noisy-le-grand macro
matin pour la démocratie et pour les
droits non en france et l'a remarqué we
made you bonaparte mais plus en egypte
et que la france où là où l'angleterre
n'administre en plus les titres que l'on
sait à l'egypte de trouver le moyen
d'aller vite comme vous l'avez dit parce
que sinon c'est charbonnier est maître
chez soi ce qu'on a dit a été clair en
38e à dire aux grenades garde à vue
débrouillez vous avec moi jouer pour
débrouille chacun donc évidemment il
doit y avoir une limite à cela le
problème c'est qu'on nous dit tous les
quatre matins qui veut c'est hitler
voulait tous les quatre matins on nous
dit qu'il ya un nid clair qu'il faut
combattre
or ça et c est 200 réseaux avec ça les
opine quand vous dites c'est hyper qui
va dire ah bah non il faut pas y aller
si voulez ça nous empêche vraiment de
penser aux cette analogie apparemment
pas et vanilla vous êtes devenu macro
nist en fait la belle le vie et c'est
marrant parce qu'en fait c'est la
première fois qu'on doit justifier à
chaque fois qu'on a pris quelque chose
et maintenant ça vous pose une question
et bien je dois dire que là dessus toute
façon moi sur ma croix n'en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure souvent ce qui
me gêne chez makro c'est pas forcément
ce qu'il dit c'est aussi ce qu'il ne dit
pas parfois est par ailleurs en
politique étrangère
je suis séduite par ce langage qui ne va
pas dans le sens du vent qui dit les
choses clairement vous l'avez rappelé
jeudi à l'ats les gîtes sa légitimité
c'est quand même effectivement de
défendre les intérêts de la france et
pas d'aller faire le beau devant les
caméras et devant les associations en
disant regardez comme je suis un bon
défenseur de ces merveilleux droits de
l'homme que nous avons inventé et bien
sûr qu'il est pour les droits de l'homme
évidemment eh bien on va voir si vous
êtes tout autant macro nist quand vous
réagirez à la désignation du patron de
la république en marche au cas où vous
n'auriez pas suivi je vous rappelle que
parti du président de la république
attend la l'élection de son délégué
général
enfin l'élection c'est un bien grand mot
parce que d'après ce qu'on a compris le
président choisit et ensuite les 380
mille adhérents sont invités s'ils le
souhaitent a validé ce choix
finalement le choix et les fesses et
christophe castaner donc le porte parole
du gouvernement et secrétaire d'état aux
relations avec le parlement
c'est quand même étonnant une drôle de
façon de procéder dans ça vous choque
pas que ce soit l'occasion n'a as public
qui choisissent le pad l'entreprise eak
rangs du parti
on pourrait en fait un truc qui
s'appelle une élection oui alors qu'au
sens où emmanuel macron a prétendu qu'il
allait révolutionner la politique
désormais il y aurait un mouvement est
pas un parti que celle est complètement
différent de ce qu'on avait connu
jusqu'à présent
si vous y avez cru évidemment c'est
choquant mais comme c'est pas exactement
mon cas que je crois que les partis
politiques ont à ça on sait au moins 1
euro 1 une légitimité un rôle qui est de
gagner les élections de permettre au
pouvoir d'exercer son quand ils sont
dans la majorité pouvoir d'un
gouvernement pendant d'exercer son
pouvoir
je ne suis pas surpris que la démarche
ne soit pas nécessairement démocratique
donc franchement avec avec ce que les
primaires ont fait au parti mais écoutez
je vais devenir vraiment ça m'étonne de
vouloir défendre à ce point le basis mme
parce que en réalité s'il l'avait fait
s'il avait fait semblant finalement
qu'est ce qui se serait passé macro
aurait choisi des rieurs non on te dira
parti du président ça vous étonne qu il
s'est toujours passé noël parce que
c'est quand même une erreur dans le sens
où il aurait pu profiter de cette
opportunité pour faire émerger des
personnalités parce que le problème dans
marche aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya aucune
personnalité autre que celle de
maquereaux et de quelques personnalités
politiques connues mais c'était
l'occasion justement de montrer qu'il ya
un véritable parti derrière et non pas
juste une machine électorale et c'était
l'occasion de faire émerger des
personnalités politiques qui auraient pu
débattre entre elles au sein même dans
marche et il a raté une occasion la ans
je pense en affirmant encore une fois et
ça ça renforce le sentiment que les
français ont déjà que autour de macron
c'est qui m'aime me suive aucune tête ne
dépasse
et surtout on ne conteste pas les choix
du chef et la c
non je pense pas que ce soit non je
pense sincèrement non c'est vrai il ne
coupe pas avec les traditions politiques
des autres partis il aurait fait la même
chose et il a raté un sens une occasion
de faire émerger son parti au delà de sa
présidence il a peut-être pas envie ça
se sont peut-être pas de bons candidats
pour car ils avaient peut-être mais ce
qui est logique de la vème république à
leur maximum et contre contrairement
aussi est ce qu on a vu qu'ils avaient
qu'on ait beaucoup vie cru qu augmenter
pendant la campagne présidentielle
là où je suis moins catégorique qui vise
à mettre les vis et je pense quand même
qu'on veut pas aller prendre
l'absence d'élection des candides des
prêts dont deux partis et des candidats
potentiels aux élections comme un fait
acquis vers qu' il ya quand même eu des
primaires pour l'ensemble des parties
j'ai du mal à croire personnellement
qu'on puisse revenir à 6 m qui seraient
de la même façon je ne peux pas mais
excusez moi c'est une très mauvaise
chose parce que c'est une mode qui n'a
pas pas retiré un parti si vous laissez
pas fait pour se chamailler pendant des
plombes à sur son leader et de faire des
élections plus ou moins réussie s'est
fait normalement ils ont déjà travaillé
sur leur pré masques et non plus
travailler sur leur programme comme
c'est quand même il ya quand même
quelque chose que je sais combien ont
par ailleurs mené par don mario là où je
suis d'accord en dégoût c'est que la
vieille politique ressemble beaucoup à
l'ancienne mais moi je n'ai pas
l'impression que dans les parties que ce
soit les républicains ou au psg encore
quelqu'un qui répond au téléphone j'ai
pas l'impression qu'on se félicite
tellement du processus des primaires
surtout qu'on a trouvé quelqu'un
d'absolument remarquable avec christophe
castaner si vous en doutiez encore je
propose d'écouter ce témoignage émouvant
de nicole belloubet la garde des sceaux
c'était ce matin sur france info il un
candidat la république en marche parce
qu'en fait il a été choisi par emmanuel
macron oui et alors la très démocratique
ça non plus écoutez moi je considère que
le parti du président de la république
mérite d'avoir à sa tête quelqu'un qui
est tout à fait dynamique rassembleur
porteur d'une logique très clair d'une
vie
ibilité d'une pugnacité christophe je
croirais point tout c'est cathy toutes
ces qualités là et je suis certaine que
les adhérents de la république en marche
seront très heureux d'avoir quelqu'un
comme lui à leur tête ça fait un peu
design manga du parti communiste chinois
écoutez moi il faut prendre les choses
telles qu'elles sont nous vivons dans un
système monarchique il été créé par le
général de gaulle
avant il y avait le régime des partis
ils mépriser ouvertement le régime des
partis la fin d'un discours à bayeux en
46 contre le régime des partis et il est
nul pour faire une autre une autre une
autre constitution pour remettre je
dirais des partis à leur place les
partis ne sont sont par ailleurs
distingué superbement au cours des dix
dernières années dans les initiatives
qui l'ont amené dans le débat d'idées
non résidentiels ni ni à la ville ni sur
la droite menée sur la gauche des rôles
et les français défendent n ont pas d un
amour fou pour leur parti c'est pas
quelque chose qui passionne les français
et je vois pas c'est pas ça on aurait
aimé que ce fusent des boîtes à idées
mandat ils ont ils ont montré que ce
nous sommes n'étaient que ça ne l'était
pas donc en fait
emmanuel macron à maui des rois de
france qu'il a gagné à la fois la
présidentielle et les législatives c'est
à dire que en fait les français ont
confirmé leur adhésion emmanuel macron
c'est ça en fait à les séduire on
confirme voilà et donc ce qu'il faut
effectivement ce qui donne un homme à
lui pour tenir le parti pour peut-être
pour en faire aussi une boîte à idées
pour que pour que des ide erreurs mais
mais ce qui faut qu'il fasse c'est
qu'ils gouvernent c'est dire que il
parle
- peut-être enfin qui vraiment qu'on
fasse enfin là il a quand même fait des
ordonnances importante qui est des vrais
changements une vraie réforme pour que
enfin la france ne soit pas le petit
dernier de la classe européenne et un
chômage à 4 % comme comme l'allemagne
voilà voilà voilà c'est ce sur quoi on
attend manuel mâcon et par exemple aussi
qu'ils fassent les vrais les formes à
l'école par exemple l'indicé
non ce qui est très bien parti qui veut
faire appel qu'ils vont lire compte
écrire etc
mais qu on rétablit qu'on était bien sûr
mais bien sûr qu'ils comptent bien sûr
bien sûr mais je me moque de ce que
pense hélas pas la pensée politiquement
correct de ce que je dis bien sûr puis
il faut de la sélection l'université
l'université ne doit pas c'est un peu un
gain voilà c'est un vélo année la
république en marche
voilà je verse une pièce au dossier et
ensuite je passe la parole maintenant
les internautes du figaro qu on a
questionné sur ce sujet est ce le rôle
d' emmanuel macron de désigner le
nouveau patron à un public en marche par
le trouve plutôt que c'est pas le job du
président de la république
je précise tout de suite sous le regard
attentif de mieux faire que ce n'est pas
un sondage mais une question
d'organisation d'élections la base du
volontariat
est-ce que c'est toujours cette
proportion pour le maquereau je sais pas
ils sont pas ils sont pas toujours aussi
mac rognac bouches et réalise avec les
villes je suis d'accord avec tout ce qui
a été dit mais comme il faut quand même
con côté libanais ressorte un peu
amnésique pas tout à fait rassurant que
les français ne voient pas au niveau et
aucun problème que les français trouvent
aucun problème à ce que le président
concentre tous les pouvoirs
je suis d'accord et se définit on est
dans le pardon alors nous on est on est
dans un régime qui est plus monarchiste
démocratique et on a mais c'est emmanuel
macron accélère des tendances mais je
pense que c'est vrai le plus insolent
nombre d'années on a un déclin de
l'esprit démocratique en france
ils se voient dans le contrôle des
libertés publiques dans la
centralisation du pouvoir dans aussi une
certaine censure morale du débat public
mais aussi les libertés individuelles
qui personnellement ne me voir pour
parler de censure dans le débat public
elisabeth lévy encore leur est mieux que
moi mais je crois que déjà on en parlera
tout à l'heure dans une certaine et
d'élections là on a voté quoi six fois
une fois dix fois que maintenant en
commun de ford à voter mais ça ne veut
pas dire que la publie ce lundi
des solutions si vous voulez vous prenez
le fonctionnement institutionnel de la
vème république poussée à son extrême
par emmanuel macron c'est l'hyper
centralisation une manière de gouverner
qui ait de la régulation administrative
qui progressivement à éliminer
l'ensemble des contre-pouvoirs et
s'attaque au dernier qu'aujourd'hui
celui il celui des collectivités locales
je trouve pas que ce soit un bon signe
je crois pas que ce soit un bon signe
que l'état d'urgence soit soit prolongée
sans même qu'ils aient de débats sur le
soleil soleil sur la liberté publique en
france sont en fait soit un bon signe
qu'on propose comme vous l'avez suggéré
tout à l'heure par en rapportant les
propos du gouvernement qu'on fasse des
des lois qu'on sanctionnant les dd
incertain certains discours expliquer
les exactement les termes je pense qu'il
ya un déclin de l'esprit démocratique
aujourd'hui et le fait que les français
voient aucun problème à ce que le
gouvernement soit un peu autocratique
est à mon sens inquiéter là il s'agit de
son parti franchement je veux dire je
pense que les français se fichent
éperdument de qui décide ce qui choisit
le patron non vraiment ce sont plein de
petits signaux faibles
oui enfin mais le reste le reste je
trouve qu'il ya des éléments avec
lesquels je suis d'accord mais sa 6e
sélection on avait eu du bit et de
remarques de défense que plus tôt je
pense en réalité que les français n'y a
rien qui les ont quittés une puisque les
chicaillas séoul et on a passé un
quinquennat avec les sky entre les
frondeurs et la présidence
franchement c'est suffisant je pense la
gagner et on verra ça avec une guerre
ouverte
à droite aussi tous les grands leaders
de la droite s'injurier dans la presse
interposée ouverte aujourd'hui alors
qu'aujourd'hui la droite tout va bien on
va
vibrer la réaction de damien qui nous
dit il est bizarre que françois bayrou
ne se manifeste pas à la tête de la
république en marche
quant à marie elle pense que c'est cool
parce que christophe casanave vient de
la société civile oui enfin il était
quand même parlementaire et déjà déjà
déjà élus et membres du pis aux côtés
ips territoriale est absolument la
droite et 20 parlons-en
les républicains sont ils les plus
belles du monde paraphraser le titre
d'un livre célèbre je vous rappelle
l'anr épisode de la deûle à la
tragi-comédie de l'expulsion des
responsables républicains constructif
c'est à dire soutenant plus ou moins
ouvertement emmanuel macron le bureau
politique qui s'est réuni hier
bah finalement on ne les a pas exclues
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas assez
nombreux pour prendre la décision
rachida dati dans un tout et là c'est
drôle vous dit que hier soir c'était le
dîner de cons
laurent wauquiez le probable le futur
patron du parti n'est pas loin de penser
comme rachida dati
il l'a dit ce matin sur france inter
pour celles à la politique ressemble un
mauvais gag et hier c'était le cas où on
s'est retrouvés puneet qu'on dit rachida
dati pour redonner la fra cc en plus y
avait rien à manger au moins ça c'est un
film que j'aime bien mais en tout cas
offert trouvait à compter des croix sur
une feuille de présence et il vaut mieux
parfois effectivement prendre le parti
d'en rire avec l'aviron nous avons
repris le micro
mais puisque c'est à dire dites le nous
est ce que vous êtes choqué qu'on
n'arrive pas à exclure des gens qui sont
plus dans la majorité que dans
l'opposition je la publie je me suis
surtout pas seulement choquée je suis
consterné si vous voulez parce que je
pense dans un sens que ma kron a fait
une sorte à opérer mission de
clarification et là c'est l'ump est ce
dont nous parlions temps si vous voulez
il ya le bloc central de la société
française qui n'avait aucune raison si
vous venez de ne pas voter pour les
mêmes gens et il n'y avait aucune raison
que françois hollande et alain juppé se
chamaillent si vous voulez leurs
représentants devraient pouvoir
se retrouver travailler ensemble
puisqu'il n'y a pas de position
idéologique entre donc je pense qu'il
peut tout ça devrait se faire sur la
forme d'un divorce à l'amiable
les gens qui veulent une droite disons
plus populiste un peu plus conservatrice
que celle de que le progressisme macro
nière le propose je devrais partir
essayé de ramasser une partie du front
national avec laquelle ils peuvent
s'entendre et laisser les autres années
chez mclaren est arrêté pour gagner
comment ça fera une majorité sans tous
les cas moi sur les bras on en avait
déjà parlé c'est que toutes ces années
si vous voulez on a perdu un temps
énorme parce que les frontières
politiques les clivages politiques ne
correspondait plus à aucun clivage
idéologique et moyennant quoi on avait
deux grands partis dans tous les cas
pour parler des républicains parce que
peut-être vous avez des certainement des
choses à retenir et roanne puisque vous
êtes à la villa la faune de la pole
pendant toutes ces années au lieu de
faire un travail idéologique que c'est à
dire un éclaircissement qu'est ce qu'on
pense sur l'europe parce qu'on est
plutôt juppé ou est-ce qu'on est plutôt
je ne sais pas qui des souverainistes
qu'est ce qu'on peut je connais plutôt
wauquiez qu'est ce qu'on pense sur
l'immigration qu'est ce qu'on pense sur
l'intégration
au lieu de ça c'est voulaient ils ont
passé leur temps metz le couvercle par
dessus et moi je crois que si on veut
si un parti politique veut être utile à
son pays qu'il faut qu'ils proposent
lumineux une vision du monde et il l'a
proposeront pas tant qu'ils seront tous
ensemble je précise que si solaires dit
qu'il peut pas rester pardo solaires dit
qu'il aime beaucoup et qui peut écouter
des discours de ma chronique au bout de
cinq minutes de bloquer un élan ils
doivent tirer tellement ils n'en peuvent
plus je comprends pas moi le signe que
cissé c'est constructif c'est à dire à
la fois les membres du gouvernement
tolère série sur les membres du
gouvernement qui sont en commande qui
sont encore font encore partie des cas
ou bien des parlementaires comme thierry
solère n'ont pas été exclus c'est parce
que le quorum n'avait pas été atteint
parce qu'il y avait des gens qui
n'étaient pas là des gens qui n'étaient
pas là c'était alain juppé jean pierre
raffarin valérie pécresse ou xavier
bertrand donc ça confère un peu ce que
vous disiez il habite les wilayas de ces
deux de ces deux lignes dont l'unique
voie en s'abstenant
on voit bien qu'elles prennent d'eux
il ya deux ans il ya vraiment deux
lignes serait ce que jean-luc historique
important risque de livres de lignes
historiques adroit qui salissent
seulement 15 ans oui c'est ça l'ump est
et 2002 donc ça fait seulement 15 ans
que la droite a réussi à se réunir et
depuis toujours la droite a été séparée
entre une droite plutôt centre droit
sagna l'idf doigts
voilà ce qui est l udf et une droite qui
était un peu plus dur qui était plus à
droite et qui était le rpr auparavant
donc aujourd'hui la scission finalement
c'est un retour à l'ordre normal des
choses j'ai envie de ça n'aura pas de
droit de friction entre n'est qu'à mon
avis sans clarification
non non oui oui ça paraît simple à leurs
blessures
c'est vrai que les deux les deux c'est
vrai ce qui est bête
il ya deux grandes questions aujourd'hui
il y a où il ya trois grandes questions
politiques
il ya l'europe l'europe nous zèle thèmes
favoris ce telle ou telle mauvaise pour
nous et nous appauvrit tu es donc ça il
faut il ya des gens qui pensent que
l'europe c'est une bonne chose pour
l'europe
josé qui souffre c'est une mauvaise
chose donc là il faut que
l'éclaircissement il ya l'immigration
alors pour les pour partie même des
socialistes et peut-être même de cette
droite centre gauche entre centre droit
en tout cas des socialistes ni
d'immigration c'est une chance pour la
france
alors il ya d'autres d'autres
personnalités politiques lise non
l'intégration ne se fait pas bien ne
s'est pas fait et donc tant qu'elle ne
se fait pas bien que l'assimilation ne
se fait pas il faut fermer les
frontières faut donc renoncé a beau dire
le regroupement familial
que fait la droite udf cette droite udf
avec chirac et tous ensemble fait le
roman familial en et 175 et c'est est
revenu sur une politique qu'avait fait
voilà qui est fait de gaulle en 45 2
on l'avait dit sur les faits ne renonce
l'immigration et tous les gens qui
peuvent venir de l'est qui fuyaient le
communisme ou les juifs qui avaient
survécu à la shoah et c'est hyper venez
en france
de gaulle avait dit je veux personne de
nos colonies et 7h pour ça qu'ils
s'étaient séparés c'était cruel de
l'algérie parce qu'ils disaient ils
avaient dire à peyrefitte
que voulez-vous peyrefitte ces gens là
ne sont pas des françaises ne veut pas
de colombey les deux mosquées
et puis qui est un revirement en 75 avec
chasse et puis depuis on a cette
immigration massive a causé des
problèmes en france il faut le dire
voilà il ya des problèmes et il ya des
gens qui considèrent qu' on peut
continuer de la saison et ma le
troisième sujet c'est le socialisme
comme il est c'est à dire fait payer les
riches
et ça c'est mélenchon c'est mélenchon il
représente question à paris c'est à dire
que des gens qui disent comme macron
c'était c'était l'intérêt de son
intervention d'autres jouent avec les
jaunes et c'était de dire il faut en
finir avec cette maladie française de la
jalousie de la jolie voiture qu'on va
rayer parce qu'on est sérieux que ce
qu'on veut pas leur sentiment du
ressentiment
il faut au contraire donner des
occasions des opportunités risque à se
développer
débat là enfin c'est plutôt mélenchon
qui le kiné pas alors voilà alors la
troisième débat c'est que les gens se
prononcer là dessus
est ce que on fait payer les riches ou
est ce qu'on considère que c'est
contreproductif et ou au contraire il
faut faire revenir les listes grises un
v6 et elle se débat et ce débat c'est
très intéressant mais aussi au front
national
absolument philippot il est plutôt bon
faire payer les riches
marion maréchal-le pen elle est plutôt
pour faire revenir les jeux on va
écouter ce qu'on peut savoir le nom mais
on va faire un petit tour par les
réseaux sociaux jean baptiste maire
géantes du figaro.fr nous a rejoint
qu'est ce qu'on dit de de ce sujet grand
débat beaucoup de réactions dans tous
les sens j'ai identifié quelques
internautes intéressant l'exclusion dé
constructif n'est pas la solution de
grâce
remettons nous au travail c'est urgent
c'est un pas cette comédie de procédure
ça c'est thomas qui est militant
républicain qui s'énerve un petit peu
les commentaires arrivent de partout
jean luc moudenc qui est jean luc monnet
le maire de toulouse
centre gauche droite centre droit de
mémoire merci guillaume françois
préfecture et donc jean luc moudenc
regard est une exclusion qui est pour
lui la facilité cela permet d'éliminer
la préfecture de région quand même merci
de tous les maux cela permet d'éliminer
écoutons les réseaux sociaux cela permet
d'éliminer certaines idées pourtant
nécessaire au rassemblement de la droite
et du centre
en face nous avons nadine morano qui a
fait de grandes performances qui s'est
beaucoup exprimée notamment dick et
constructif critique les lr matin midi
et soir et refuse de partir on les vit
elle s'accroche comme des moules au
rocher le sens de l'image et elle a va
un peu plus loin il s'en prend
directement à thierry solère dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
en plus d'être un traître tu es vraiment
un sale type n'est pas une réponse non
le choisit directement
tout ça n'est qu'un débat poursuivre les
gens matin sera donc benoît lui simples
internautes
il y voit une stratégie de emmanuel
macron quand même à nu la crau aura
détruit les alertes
on se débarrassera dé constructif comme
il l'a fait avec les modems nicolas lui
est naturellement ça lui plaît il est
allé république en marche il félicite
pendant que la république en marche
rassemble autour d'un axe central les
républicains exclu divisé dérive vers
l'extrême droite positionnement
justement notre rpr qui va vers plus à
droite et enfin petit soupçon d'ironie
d'un internaute qui s'appelle la
deuxième à droite prédit qu'à ce rythme
c'est les constructif qui vont finir par
exclure des républicains ça c'est votre
merci jean baptiste eyraud nanan en
quelques vous d'abord parce que
effectivement tout le monde est d'accord
que c'est assez pathétique cet imbroglio
autour de l'exclusion ou non les
républicains ont été assez idiot il
aurait rien fait dans un an avec laurent
wauquiez président du parti s'arrêter
aux premiers ministres edouard philippe
au ministre de
re qui ont rejoint emmanuel accros de se
positionner de dire si oui ou non ils
quittaient leur parti où il y restait y
adhérer à la ligue que laurent wauquiez
aura défini ça c'est hélas hélas
aujourd'hui écoutés oui mais aujourd'hui
ils sont une situation qui est
absolument absolument ridicule alors je
suis partiellement d'accord avec ce qu'a
dit elisabeth lévy je pense
qu'effectivement les parties ou un grave
problème de ligne politique qui n'a pas
été définie depuis longtemps et que
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont avec eux mêmes
la crau emmanuel macron a pu gagner
l'élection présidentielle puis
législatives toutefois je crois je suis
pas convaincu les clivages soit
exactement aussi précisément ce
contretemps a pu discuter je pense que
il ya quelque chose qui reste commun
entre ces deux droites qui font qu'ils
ne sont pas de gauche et que depuis 15
ans leurs difficultés ce qu'il tourne
autour d'une manière de réformer l'état
providence ils savent pas trop quoi en
fait ils savent pas quelles lignes
inventé c'est vrai de la droite
française c'est vrai de l'ensemble des
droites européennes face à un état qui a
fait faillite qu'est ce qu'on fait et il
ya une autre question une question des
lits est notre question une question de
la stratégie qui est maintenant quelle
que soit la ligne comment est ce qu'on
fait pour
comment la droite fait pour gagner le
pouvoir hélas la stratégie de laurent
wauquiez dire je pars d'un socle de
droite et je re et jeu en faisant
concurrence au fn parce que si c'est pas
moi ça sera le fn
et même si je suis pas convaincu par
toujours par la ligne qui n'est pas
toujours libéral de laurent wauquiez
quand on regarde les pays les autres
pays d'europe les autres pays
occidentaux
force est de reconnaître que c'est
probablement une voie qui peut prospérer
je donne vincent mais personne ne m'a
pas je veux pas alors 15e comment je
crois que j'oublie mon idée
heureusement et me leclerc lui la rente
est enfoui natoire ne repasse pas les
plats assez rapide parce qu'on avait
interrogé justement les français et
particulièrement les sympathisants les
républicains sur ces questions de
l'exclusion se trouve logique qu'on
exclue au moins parce qu'on avait
détaillé on avait fait une sorte de
graduation au moins pour ceux qui sont
rentrés au gouvernement parce qu'il ya
une logique évidente on peut pas à la
fois être dans le gouvernement et dans
un parti qui se réclament de
l'opposition
en revanche pour les dépenses fixes et
les touches qui promet sylvie à bénodet
d'edouard cissé finale et pour les
députés en revanche si c'était un peu
moins favorable et les les sympathisants
à l'air puisqu'il considère aussi qu'on
peut par moment voter une loi vu le
gouvernement propose si elle correspond
aux commissions aux convictions de
droite aux conditions du parti et qu'il
y à vous souvenez on a beau et c'était
la réussite de maquereaux finalement
c'était de dépasser les clivages
partisans sur les questions qui était
idéologique et pourquoi ne vous
traiteront pas une loi émise par un
autre parti par principe juste parce
qu'elle est émise par l'autre partie de
fournir les gens peuvent comprendre
certaines places comme dé constructif
on sait que la grèce il ya quand même un
clivage qu'il n'ait pas dit là dedans je
pense que renault a annoncé trois
clivage importante bien que sur l'europe
se soit pas on est pourrez vous en avez
un quatrième si vous voulez mais yat-il
ne sommes qu il faut parler aux perdants
culturel
il me semble que la droite sur les
macron parle en quelque sorte avec le
start up isme le progressisme le parton
en commun et faire écho qu'il veut
parler il veut parler aux gagnants
culturel
or il faut une droite qui perle qui
parle aux perdants culturelles qui sont
pour autant le cateau de versailles que
le prolo du nord si vous voulez des gens
qui se font traiter toute la journée en
gros de résidus je vous promets qu'on y
reviendra
mais je voudrais qu'on parle aussi d'un
tintin tergnier sujet oui je
autour du harcèlement sexuel avec depuis
les révélations concernant un producteur
hollywoodien il y a acheté à valence ton
port invitant les femmes victimes de
harcèlement à se manifester
il y à des déclarations publiques de
toujours plus nombreuses le dernier à la
dernière en date pardon concerne le
président george bush senior 93 ans est
une actrice américaine qui l'a rencontré
qui s'appelle isr linde dit il m'a
touché par derrière depuis sa chaise
roulante alors que sa femme barbara bush
se trouvait à ses côtés
il se passe pas de jour quasiment sans
qu'il y ait des révélations de ce type
elisabeth lévy vous vous avez écrit un
article assez fort qu'il appelle le
grand d'eilat ont pour pour critiquer
cette cette opération balances ton port
votre article disponible en ligne
d'ailleurs on peut on peut aussi référé
je vais vous poser question un peu
personnel parce que vous en parlez dans
votre article vous dites moi je n'ai pas
de porc a dénoncé ça veut dire qu' il
n'y a pas de fatalité à ce harcèlement
qui semble être généralisée si on en
croit tous les médias non mais non
seulement il ya pas de fatalité il ya
évidemment pas de fatalité mais surtout
le phénomène est beaucoup moins ample
que ce qu'on nous raconte
si vous voulez à en croire maintenant
les enquêtes sait il n'ya pas une femme
qui n'est pas été victime a sauté la
réalité est ce que c'est la réalité des
relations entre les hommes et les femmes
dans notre pays
est-ce que et puis par ailleurs vous
m'arrêtez quand j'ai trop parlé parce
que ce sujet me rend folle mais je pense
que c'est très grave parce que sous
prétexte d'attendre la justice d'accord
on suspend les garanties les plus
élémentaires qui préside à notre justice
ça s'appelle l'habeas corpus et même pas
nous qui l'avons inventé désolé c'est
qui ça c'est et c'est bien avant la
démocratie c'est que quand on accuse un
bon homme ou une femme évidemment de
quelque chose on va le chercher par le
colback et on lui dit viens ici voilà ce
conte reproche répond ça c'est le
minimum c'est le vraiment c'est au coeur
de notre système avec ce qui est en
train de se passer
la fille qui a posté le premier message
demande des noms et elles demandent des
détails
et bien non il ne suffit pas que
quelqu'un dit
pour dire x y ou z maps et si oui ça
pour que ce soit vrai cela donne ça
serait pas sur les réseaux sous voilà
onze ans et c'est juste la deuxième
chose la définition du harcèlement là ça
commence à bien faire
si vous voulez parce que dans tous les
récits que nous avons donc il y a des
filles qui sont agressés vraiment qu'on
oblige il y a des filles qui sont
l'objet de chantage de chantage d'un
type qui leur disent si tu passes pas la
casserole tu n'auras pas ceci ou cela le
reste des cas ce sont des gens des
hommes qui ont tenté leur chance
voilà et tout d'un coup on voit alors
d'une façon plus ou moins votre compte
au moins intelligente je veux dire je ne
dis pas que cette agréable pour une
comédienne
si vous voulez quand tati puis dit est
ce que tu voudrais bien me regarde et me
masturber c'est pas agréable mais qu'on
me dise qu'elle est traumatisée jusqu'à
la fin de ses jours et qu'elle n'a pas
pu se remettre et qu'elle n'a rien dit
en plus parce qu'il fallait pas énerver
le grand producteur excusez moi je veux
dire soit je ne vis pas dans le même
monde je ne vis pas dans un monde où les
femmes sont dans leur ensemble sans
défense et je ne parle pas de la
caissière qui voit son chef de rayon
la halle harcelé les journalistes
politiques qui pleurnichent toute la
journée
si vous voulez ne sont pas des faibles
femmes sans défense qui n'ont qu'un
moyen de riposter un homme et on peut
pas moi je crois à l'égalité des sexes
ça veut dire que dans un très grand
nombre de cas dans un très grand nombre
de cas je veux dire on peut riposter et
où devrait réserver toute notre
indignation aucun réellement douloureux
au lieu d'encourager toutes les femmes à
dire moi aussi je t'ai victime me to re
est ce que vous voyez l'horreur de ce
hashtag victime toi c'est à dire que
cinq ehpad xml va se sentir vraiment
excusez moi c'est ce que c'est une vrai
que ma génie bastille qu'il n'est pas
suspecte de ne pas être comment dire
on n'est pas envie de la regarder et
bien c'est à dire elle m'a dit mais
c'est donc je me sens donc c'est vrai on
a l'impression que si on ne raconte pas
nous aussi notre lot d'horreur qui nous
aurait été pattes
jadis on n'est pas ou n'existe pas
vraiment et pourtant m me le maire
parlant et pourtant me le faire oui si
on en croit les sondages il ya beaucoup
de françaises qui considèrent qu'elles
ont été alors on a interrogé les france
les françaises et les français
d'ailleurs parce que les hommes ça peut
leur arriver c'est 10% se dit option
exactement mais chez les femmes c'est
bien plus élevé et c'est assez logique
c'est une femme sur deux qui nous dit
avoir déjà été victimes de harcèlement
ou d'une agression sexuelle un élément
intéressant aussi c'est plus on est
jeune bizarrement on pourrait croire que
plus on avance dans l'âge plus on a de
chances d'avoir été une fois harcelés
dans sa vie ce serait logique et bien
non c'est l'inversé les plus jeunes
femmes qui nous disent avoir été plus
tard celui-ci pourquoi peut-être parce
qu'on oublie peut-être même peut-être
parce que la définition et le sentiment
a changé aussi
et que les choses ont changé et qu'il
faut accepter puisque aujourd'hui les
femmes nous le disent quand on leur
demande est ce que c'est un problème
important et nous le disent et les
français de manière générale nous disent
oui c'est un problème très important
donc on est obligé de l'accepter parce
qu'il juge je ne dis pas que je dis pas
qu'il faut l'accepter ou quoi que ce
soit je dis simplement que les français
et les françaises c'est un problème
important
ils sont même très favorables à des à
des projets de loi on les avait
interrogé sur le projet de one man n ya
pas donc oui c'est un problème de
société héricy comptes qui doit porter
de débats après je ne vais pas me
plaindre ce n'est sûr mais en tout cas
c'est un sujet dont on le connaît on
voit cette histoire de cette actrice qui
étaient complètement inconnus et qui
n'ont de ce fait un coup de pub en
disant que de sa chaise à roulettes
le président a joué mais en fait je n'y
crois pas une seconde
et quand bien même et quand des élus
auraient mis la main au fait c'est quoi
et on a et je vais faire une
rétrospective retros mais vous allez
prendre vous à l'épreuve et une défense
rétrospective de mike tyson
mike tyson je perds le processus est
très dangereuse que le procès mike tyson
oui le boxeur il ya tout ce qui est
avéré au procès à toulouse tout le monde
est d'accord procès c'est qu'il ya une
jeune personne qui se vante auprès de
ses copines qu'elle va se faire mal
texte donc elle va coucher avec lui et
qu'elle va entreprendre de pouvoir
projet voilà elle tout ça tout le monde
est d'accord avec ça parce que la
conversation
leye des témoins ensuite elle monte dans
la chambre de michael sohn d'accord et
elle accepte la et tout le monde est
tous d'accord
elle accepte de se déshabiller elle
monte à 2 heures du matin elle n'est pas
forcé elle y va elle même et après sur
le fait l'acte sexuel elle dit est ce
plat qu'elle a été violée
mike tyson a pris dix ans de prison il
avait 10 ans de prison ferme c'est ce
que ce qu'il faut faire ou en france
pour comprendre dit non
là il ya quand même là il faut quand
même excusez-moi j'ai été un peu les ja
il faut stop il faut pas déconner quoi
mais tous ces cadres et tout s'est
quasiment pas là et ron le nom sur ce
qu'elle est là je le connais pas je peux
en parler mais la qualité jugée par
l'institution judiciaire indépendant
juste je moi j'aime pas non plus
l'ambiance de délation les deux gens qui
sont condamnés avant d'être jus avant
même d'avoir été jugé pour autant comme
il faut quand même si les femmes
s'exprime de cette façon c'est qu'il ya
quand même dans la société française un
sentiment partagé puis doublement par
vous l'avez dit par un grand nombre de
femmes qu'elles ne sont pas respectés
que dans pour le coup pour le voir on
dans le milieu politique aussi beaucoup
l'idée que si les femmes sont là c'est
parce qu'elles ont couché que si elles
sont là c'est uniquement pour leur
physique et je crois effectivement que
ce mouvement s'il a des défauts il a un
avantage c'est qu'il donne à la
a suffisamment de confiance s'installe
entre deux femmes pour dire mais moi
aussi à un moment je me fais pas marché
je me fais je ne me fais plus marcher
dessus et vous avez raison elles peuvent
répondre mais là certaines qui n'osent
pas après est-ce que c'est là le
principal
est ce que c'est le seul problème
aujourd'hui des femmes dans la société
française je pense pas je pense que pont
pour bien connaître par ailleurs des
quartiers difficiles
il ya là un vrai problème de droits des
femmes dont on ne parle pas les femmes
ne sont pas respectés les femmes
hésitent à l'est mais l'endroit est bien
tiré le président macro on a parlé d'un
essai de cronje mais bien aujourd'hui
j'étais extrêmement écoulée de
l'entendre dire celle choses absolument
pas plausible est effacée dans les
quartiers jeu se poser c'est au manoir
une pub reculé à ma caisse longueur
c'est le mot or quand on disait cela
après colonnes caroline doit signer
disait qu'on avait de la merde raciste
dans les yeux les droits des femmes et
le respect des femmes est quand même un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui c'est française à
mon sens alors je pense que nous n'en
disconviendra pas merci à tous les
quatre pour ce débat passionnant surtout
restez connecté vous allez retrouver
dans quelques instants
l'invité de conversation avec marie
laëtitia bonavita c'est ce soir stéphane
marchand auteur d'un ouvrage sur les
secrets de votre cerveau et point de vue
ça repart demain même heure même endroit
bonsoir
[Musique]